what if you have a little Benny and he
wants to be a comic it's all good with
me so I'll go with me my parents were
incredibly supportive of me and I
couldn't have done it without their
support I mean they never questioned my
career goals was unusual for parents I
was telling positives and negatives and
I'll let them know that it's hard to do
it but if you want to do it that you
have to stick to it and you can get it
done if you're talented you got to be
honest with yourself but if you have
that talent or not you know if and I'll
burnin somebody from high school that
will you know come to a show or
something and they'll say after the show
a little be like man you're living the
dream they have this like wistfulness
and their voyage they wish they were
doing that and they feel the most
conveying in that question like that
they are not living their dream and I
think that's the saddest thing possible
because not everybody is supposed to
live their fantasy dream their childhood
I want to be an astronaut or a comedian
or an actor or a ballplayer dream those
probably most of the time are stupid
dreams to continue having once you grow
up but your dream should be the choices
you make your dream should be the life
that you choose because every minute
that banker or that accountant could
quit and pursue comedy if you really
want to be if that's his dream that's
the dream to do that and if you don't do
that then your dream is not doing that
you've chosen to not do that and it's
often a better choice to not pursue your
passions as your job because then your
job comedy that I loved in my heart
becomes a business you have to figure
out how to tweet in the right time of
day that I get to seem that most
audience and complainin interviews about
not getting enough retweets and all that
kind of thing whereas that guy gets to
just do his job he chose hopefully
this'll service to the community or to
the world and then even if that's
cleaning up someone's garbage or serving
them food mcdonalds or whatever might be
those are all very valuable services and
then they get to come home clock out of
that job at five o'clock and relax and
each day's a vacation home and watch me
make it you laugh on TV because I've
been working longer hours trying to
create entertainment that takes longer
to create so that's a dream to me I wish
often you know I don't wish I could do
that but I that is an alternate
enjoyable life that I would love to have
done if i did a different style of life
so I just think whatever you do if be
happy with it cuz you can always change
it nice and choice every second
you can change paths any second and so I
would just tell them that and also one
if i can just tag on the 10 part of the
10-year goal is I would like to be at a
place part of why I want to be able to
reach huge audiences there's a lot of
things you can do to impact things to
make change to pack the world these days
with the internet with how fast things
travel you know we've created a high of
mind for Humanity that for species
didn't have a high of mine capability
before like bees or you know certain
animals do so I would love to be able to
figure some way to just help advance the
planet in a in a more significant way
whether it's through a thoughtful show
or a foundation or a charity or
something helping kids with speech
problems or helping solves one big
calamity in the planet or or just you
know helping people have more of a
conversation that leads towards more
congruous happy chill planet that would
be very nice and you need leverage to do
that and leverage comes with broad
audience and large number of eyeballs so
I hope I get to you know like I said I'd
like pressure my shoulders I handle it
very well so the more pressure i get to
have I think the more success and and
the more effective I'll be able to be in
my life so I just really thin your plan
just a lot of pressure on my shoulders
but I like good pressure to be you know
I'm saying like good positive steam
engine pressure front facing whale Shin
not like old-school backward moving
steam wheel with like old-school
traditional whales under it who knew
this already been there and done that no
be euphemisms you're talking about a
calling a hive mentality no being
youthful mysm so you can throw on there
no I'm just gonna buzz the out of
people that are Tony yeah you know me
buzz around and then eat the honey you
have to get the honey otherwise what's
the point of all the work well what if
the queen is difficult though Green is
always difficult part of the fun of it
you